how and why did you decide to write an
anti-islamic book
how was your life in regards to Faith
what did you believe in what was your
heaviest and most regretful expression
that you used for Islam what was the
reaction of the people around you when
you became Muslim I thought to myself
Islam is a lie Islam is a danger I got
over a 2 000 death threats and in the
end I decided to write an anti-islam
book
Gods Give Me A Sign so that I 100 sure
know this is the way I couldn't sleep
for it for two days I couldn't accept it
it was so so strange as an American
brother thank you for accepting our
invitation and we are happy to have you
with us I want to first ask you who is
joram
thank you very much for the invitation
it's a great honor for me to be here
Jordan for club was born on January 23
in 1979 in Amsterdam in a pretty regular
family father mother a brother not a
brother younger a sister a cat in
Amsterdam I was born and raised there in
a we're practicing Protestant family
after I finished high school I studied
comparative religion I I was a teacher
for a few years there haven't a lot of
things in the Netherlands especially in
my life also when I look at the bigger
picture when it came to Islam I became
politically active for the Freedom Party
I became a member of Parliament and in
and I decided to write an anti-islam
book which started as an anti-islam book
changed into this search for God and it
ended up me becoming a Muslim
how was your life in regards to Faith
what did you be this is definitely a lot
better even so far than that other video
we watched where someone narrating on
his story yes well obviously hearing
right from the source is going to be
better how was your life in regards to
Faith what did you believe in before I
was a Muslim I was a Protestant
Christian from the Reformed Church we
read from the Bible we all got biblical
names we were all baptized we went to
church etc etc so we're pretty Christian
in that way in that sense of course I
believe that there is a Creator I
believed in heaven hell I believe in
angels Revelations and of course what
separates the Christians from the
Muslims is that I believe that Jesus
Christ was the son of God yeah in in a
more philosophical way I believed he was
God himself of course I believed in the
resurrection and crucifixion of Christ
of course and I believed in the
atonement so but because the Trinity is
a very complex concept whether you
believe it or not it's still very
complex because if there is a God in the
Bible it says God is eternal but if you
are Eternal and at the same in the same
you die you cannot be Eternal Immortal
at the same time so that was something
when I was a little older 1670 I started
questioning things like that it's not
very logical I talk to many many priests
preachers even rabbis and the answers I
got weren't very satisfying that made it
for me kind of complex and in the end I
had some doubts about stuff like this
but I said well I set aside and I
thought okay I just believe it and
perhaps I'm not smart enough to get the
whole picture and
um interesting because that's how I
definitely feel like a lot of people
feel about the Trinity and stuff is that
they're just like not smart enough and
it's like kind of beyond their
comprehension but then when you really
think about it does that fully make
sense because like wouldn't you rather
have something that um Clicks in your
head or am I missing something do you
know what I'm saying I do but I also
don't think that we are necessarily
capable of understanding all things
about God I agree I totally agree there
so it doesn't bother me okay
I still believed in God I still believe
that Jesus was a very important person I
believe he was the son of God but how it
exactly was I I left it for what it was
how and why did you decide to write an
anti-islamic book after high school I
went to a university and I did
comparative religion and a remarkable
thing I think was that the first day of
me going to college was September 11
2001. already thought okay guys are kind
of crazy and this religion isn't the
truth then a few years later was this
guy in the Netherlands called Teo Van
Gogh he was a famous filmmaker and he
was killed in the street he was shot and
they tried to slit his throat and they
put a knife in his stomach with a letter
on it for another girl Ayan history Ali
and it was it said you are next so it
strengthens my anti-islam feelings in
such a way that I thought well I have to
become politically active to do
something and stop this evil or harming
our country you started politics because
of Islam yeah and that really had to do
with Islam that was the reason I wanted
to write a book to it really is like
insane how like the mass perception
really is like terrorism and women don't
get rights and stuff like that it's wild
really had to do with Islam that's
what's the reason I wanted to write a
book to explain to people why Islam was
a danger for the world when I was
writing my book like I said earlier the
questions the doubts I had about
Christianity popped up again and that
was about truth of course because I was
a believing Christian guy and yeah the
Christian questions I had in the end
were answers in an Islamic way because
of course when I started writing the
book A lot of people think there was a
political book but it wasn't so much in
political book it was a religious book
because I wanted to show people why
Islam was a danger as a religion and I
wrote it from a Christian perspective so
in the beginning I made a comparison
between the Christian concept of God and
the Islamic concept so I start comparing
it but because I had these doubts about
the Trinity and I saw tawheeds the
Oneness of God in Islam said yeah it
sounds a little bit more logical and
then I thought to myself well I reread
the Bible to see to refresh myself and
say okay why isn't the concept of Islam
the tawheed concept isn't the Christian
concept but when I was reading the
oldest Testament and I saw what the Old
Testament Prophet said was one God one
God one God and then I thought okay I'll
look only at the words of Jesus Christ
in the New Testament and then there's
this story in the New Testament that
where a guy comes to Jesus and he asks
him what is the most important thing in
life how can I gain paradise and he said
there are two things he says Hear o
Israel here your God is one treat your
neighbor as you want to be treated
yourself so I thought well even Jesus
Christ says here o Israel your God is
one so I thought well this whole Muslim
concept of God sounds more logical and
it's the same concept that I find in the
old and the New Testament do you have
any thoughts so far
um I I just feel like he's getting out
of you know to the same conversation I
keep hearing about how I keep getting
these things that Jesus never said he
was God and he did multiple times the
New Testament and I know Christianity as
a religion teaches something else but it
isn't the concept of God that I find in
the Bible so after weeks and weeks of
studies we missed a lot then reading the
Bible it is very much in there where he
said he is the law of Moses and he
refers to prophecies that were were
fulfilled and that's part of the reason
that he was killed is because he said he
was God and he was one with God so I
mean it's to say that he never said that
or that he wasn't that and he wasn't
clear about that is simply just to
ignore facts
reading rereading all kinds of books I
thought to myself okay perhaps this
Oneness of God is something that is true
so that's how it started what resources
did you use while doing your research
because I was kind of shocked I started
writing to several Authorities on these
religious matters and one of the guys
that I wrote to was Sheikh Abdul
hakimurat and he's a professor from
Cambridge University but in a way it was
kind of strange of course because I was
politician back then still I was writing
an anti-islam book with an anti-islam
purpose and I'm asking this Muslim
Professor from another country can you
help me so I told him I'm writing a book
I have a lot of questions so I was very
clean why I thought why is Islam
promoting terrorism a wise anti-woman
why is anti-christian anti-w whatever
after I think six weeks he sent me a
very extensive email and he started
explaining directly answered a lot of my
questions but he also told me you have
to read this article read this book read
that book ask this person and so he was
very extensive in his way of explaining
but in the end after I read all these
books and articles and made a comparison
between prophets from the Old Testament
with Muhammad peace and blessings be
your father I had no arguments anymore
to say they are prophets and he is not
and I thought to myself well if I accept
Moses on these grounds and I cannot
accept the prophet then there is
something else so I thought why don't I
think he is a prophet and I thought oh
perhaps because he had many wives but
then again
Jesus be the Son of God and Muhammad
also be a prophet I I can't wrap my head
around why that is so hard for people to
comprehend not just because a prophet
came after Jesus that he's the only
Prophet that we should listen to at any
point in time anybody could have
believed that and you know through all
the prophets in the Old Testament at any
point they could have been like okay
we're done we got a profit we got the
message now we're good uh apparently
anyone else that comes is no longer
valid and that is not what they did God
said he was the last prophet right
Muhammad yeah Omaha
well I'm sure we'll be corrected on this
but
um the the the argument that we get is
or the logic that we get all of them has
profits but all the previous profits no
one thought that that was the last one
like people there's no message about
there being a last one or do you know
anything about that no I don't know
anything about that pretty crazy
like why would I I if he I don't think
he ever said that why wouldn't God send
you know one of the things I think it
was in the conversation with Ali dawa
when he was saying that if Jesus was God
why we he wouldn't have to send any more
prophets after that and I disagree with
that I feel like God would continue to
send prophets because we are so
constantly as a human race falling off
track more than ever I think because
we're so caught in materialism and and
ourselves and fame and whatever nonsense
that we're caught up in Tick Tock that
we need you know we need another profit
we need someone to come down and and get
real with us it is really crazy like
thinking about God is just
something yeah it is crazy to think
about it is crazy to think about but
when you because you can't even
conceptualize like what what it what God
looks like or anything like that and
it's we're saying like God as in you
know God is like this being is like
sending people down to give us a message
but we can't even like visualize what
God is and it's like that's it is like a
really it's a it's a wild thought
because we're using our tools we're
learning and understanding to understand
something that just it doesn't fit into
that Paradigm it's crazy because like
even the way like we learn language and
like when even when you're asked like
who are like who are you and you're like
I am sunny and it's like no that's not
who you are like that's the name you
were given that's not who you are you're
not and are you like are you this body
is that what you are no that's not what
you are like there's so much more to it
but like that's where I get into the
Matrix and I've been looking as like it
goes so much deeper than just like the
Tate and like the controlling stuff like
I genuinely think there's people at the
top who know like so much more about
like not even mind control but just like
if you why are people in a specific way
they won't be able to see things about
the world that you would be able to see
if you just grew up naturally am I
making sense or do I just sound crazy
yeah no word obviously yeah absolutely
you're making sense I mean that's
because like like I said you're like the
three Muslims made a good point where
they said like what are your goals and I
said to be financially independent and
free and they're like you know that
makes sense that you're saying that
growing up in a liberal capitalist
Society like in a Muslim Society those
people's main focus would to be as good
of a Muslim as possible well religion I
you know people when I talk about you
know that I'm going to church and I'm
really you know studying the Bible now
and I'm getting into it they will say
you know I had a bad experience with the
church and you know you really have to
think the church isn't God the church is
not God and the church is not a
relationship with God the church is a
way to potentially gain a relationship
with God or a way to put you know have a
community of of like-minded people but
it does it it really isn't you don't
need Church to love God and Jesus came
in and one of the things he taught was
you don't have to be in the synagogue to
to have a relationship with God and to
worship God you can do that anywhere you
can do that everywhere it was very
disruptive because the because the
synagogue and the the structure of the
religion at the time was extremely
important yeah no but so even like I
said with that example like even I'm
trying to wear this in the best way
possible so even with like the way
you're taught things from a young age so
like let's say like multiplication for
an example like the way we're taught to
do multiplication like there's ways that
you could do it more efficiently and you
could do like a lot of that math in your
head but we're taught this other way for
some reason and then that determines the
way we think right like the way you
learn like math and how to count
literally determines the way your eyes
like simply perceive stuff like why when
you look at those books for an example
why can't you just look at them and say
I know how many there are you have to go
one two three four you have to count
them and that just the way we are in the
way we were born or is that the way we
were taught to count right in the way
you've been wired since you're little
because your brain's a sponge when
you're that young you know what I mean
like you can pick up languages in months
so when they're putting that programming
into you like teaching it's just forming
the way your brain moves in society do
you see what I'm saying it's not crazy
we're taught nowadays too to think young
people are taught to think about
themselves above all how do you feel
what do you want what is your truth who
are you we're not taught to think about
how are you living
um in accordance with God's law how are
you living in accordance you know if we
were all if we all had that one
aspiration as our main aspiration to
have a relationship with God and to live
in accordance with these rules that were
set out for us by the prophets we would
then be able to take all those other
things money uh creative achievements
medical achievements all the things that
you know we are called to do and look at
them as God gave us gifts and we're
gonna now you know do our best in order
to fulfill that them to be those people
so that alone has taught us you know
that if that's not part of your of your
ingrained in you from a child and what
you're thinking you have to find it on
your own when you're older or never find
it that's also an option it's crazy that
some people do just like never touch it
into spirituality or even think about it
we call them NPCs but it's like there's
people who just do no self-analysis they
just go about life they go home they
watch TV and that's that's that's it
they don't like look themselves in the
mirror so we have to take the long road
to God then because we then have to
first start to discover ourselves and
start to talk about emotional
intelligence and you know book you know
education type of intelligence and and
start understanding society and we have
to end up if we're lucky either some
people just do nothing and just exist
and run around worrying about nonsense
and some people end up taking this long
road you know what another crazy thing
that I saw today is how like science is
essentially a religion because like for
example you go on your phone and you
know that like you can get Wi-Fi and you
can get access to the internet by being
on your phone and you know that that's
technically like science some sort of
science because you can go on your phone
and directly see it now how much science
is there that you just can't see it's
based off of just you being told that
that's science so if you're all in on
science but there's so much stuff that
you can't even see with your own eyes or
understand then doesn't that essentially
make that like you know like a religion
like like science in some sense is just
like as much of a belief as religion I
think it's a little bit different
because I think it through science it's
like the big bang for example the big
bang for example like we don't know that
happened it's called The Big Bang Theory
well it's still a theory right we've
talked about that yeah but it's taught
it's like fact basically like everyone
thinks that the world just started with
big bang and then you're like like
molecules going this to this big and
then it creates everything like that's a
belief in itself so you're gonna you'd
rather choose to believe what humans
came up with for their for their thesis
rather than going with God but that's a
thesis they're both equal beliefs though
that's the thing and it's crazy to think
about Abraham there are a lot of people
in the Old Testament that had more wives
and when you look at even outside of the
religious books culturally in Europe in
Africa Asia everywhere there were men
with several wives for several reasons
so I thought to myself well that cannot
be a reason either so one by one all
these reasons fell and in the end I
thought well I have to say all of them
are not prophets but I I didn't believe
that because I thought well the things
they did they said the Miracles of
Heaven Etc they were confirmed in what
they said and what they did so they are
and then I said well then I have to
accept that Prophet Muhammad perhaps is
a prophet too so I was doubting it so
first I thought well it's the most evil
person I know because of the history
then I said well perhaps it's not that
evil but he's not a prophet and in the
end I started doubting perhaps he is a
prophet yeah that took of course me
reading a lot of books again and the one
thing that I think was very wise of
Abdul hakimurat to say was he said well
the books you read about with the
anti-islam argument moments are written
by non-muslims he said if you want to
know more about Christianity you don't
read books from atheists you start
reading the books from the Christians
why do they believe this what are the
arguments so that you have to do the
same with Islam so start reading Islamic
books from Islamic teachers from Islamic
scholars Etc and then you can see if you
compare the books on the same topic of
people who are Muslim and wrote those
books and non-muslims you can see where
they took the wrong turn where they are
translated words in the wrong way
sometimes perhaps even not on purpose
but just because they didn't know where
things are added where things left out
of it so and in the end you see there's
this other religion almost created
because of all these things and that's
what I did and that's what I also did
with the life of the Prophet because I
read a book from Martin links the life
of the Prophet based on the earliest
source of Muhammad and it was written of
course by convert and his way of
reasoning his way of telling his way of
writing appealed to me because it's
culturally the same thing how do I
approach a certain topic Etc and it was
the first time that I saw him not so
much as a warlord because that's the
picture I had in my mind but I saw him
as a father and I saw him as a friend
and a teacher and so much more and so
yeah I saw the person in his character
and I said well I can't say a lot but I
cannot say that this is not a good man
so his character persuaded me to read
more and to want to know more what
surprised you the most while doing your
research the story about hint there was
something that like a switch like I had
to change and it was because I thought
hence was the wife of one of the enemies
Abu sufyan and in a way it gave money to
kill Hamza the favorite uncle of the
prophet and that was what happened on
the battlefield he got killed they even
paraded with his ears and cut off his
nose and horrible stuff so the prophet
was deeply sad of course what happened
and years and years later he became
powerful he came in power in Mecca and
then there was hints and I was reading
this book and I thought okay now she
gets crucified or her head gets cut off
or something like that so he was doing
all this before he ever even read the
Quran I don't know he didn't say that he
didn't say he hadn't read the Quran yet
but like he was going off about them
promoting terrorism and stuff and that's
just like not true well there are there
are people who do promote terrorism in
the name of Islam it doesn't mean that I
don't know enough to know if I guess he
just he just mixed he just mixed those
up because it's not like Islam is
promoting that like they don't promote
violence well what he's saying is that
there were misinterpretations or things
that were added deliberately or left out
deliberately or even not deliberately
and then then you end up with this
misinterpreted you know this this
Twisted version of Christianity of
excuse me of what Muhammad said
according to what he said that's what
he's saying and that that has happened
throughout the ages in Christianity also
the church today is completely out to
lunch and doesn't really not fully but
not everybody but to a great extent the
Christian churches around the world are
completely missing the point indubitably
which says well I cannot look at her
right now but everybody is Forgiven and
if you want to stay here and live among
the most Sims it's possible if you don't
want that you can go but blood shedding
is over now and I thought to myself that
she was forgiven if you can forgive
someone who kills a relative especially
a favorite uncle of you even starts
parading with parts of his body to show
other people that she humiliates you and
whatever you stand for that means you
have such a great character it's very
special it's it's something you don't
see and that's what he did so I thought
to myself well it was a really special
guy and when I thought that I thought
well I have these Arguments for him
being a prophet I see his character I
see the way he treated other people I
see how he treated his enemies I think
he is a prophet but then I thought to
myself whoa that's horrible because I
already accepted this Oneness of gods
and now I say he is a prophet if I say
there is only one God and Muhammad is
his Prophet it's almost shahada so I
thought myself okay let's close the
books if there's only one God why
couldn't that God send another Prophet
you know one of the things we talked
about with Ali dawah that he was very
intense that God is you you know
all-powerful all-knowing and he and you
know could get himself out of any
situation and then he would never debase
himself by by coming down to earth and
being Immortal and I I think I think the
fact that he did that reinforces the
fact that he is all-powerful and all
loving and he could do anything and if
he Cho and he could choose to say I'm
going to come to Earth send a son in
Earthly form who can get my message
across in a way that people will
understand and Jesus is like extremely
relatable as as a human being and he
makes he made God so accessible and that
and that's to they'll say no no God
wouldn't do that and I'm like who are
you to say what God wouldn't do doesn't
make sense to me doesn't add up don't
put limits on what God would do what I
like about Muslims is um they pray five
times a day I like that it's like
meditation right and and that's like so
important for your brain look you've
even said Christians strong Christians
pray they start their morning with
prayer is that in the Bible that you're
supposed to pray throughout the day I
don't know I I've never gotten that far
but you are we you know Jesus taught us
the Our father and we are supposed to
pray that every day when Moses pray we
are supposed to pray before we eat so
there are multiple prayers in a
Christian's life throughout the day it's
not that different yeah I think I think
they're really similar like I do it's
it's essentially the same God and they
are really similar they're both like if
you follow the books religiously
it's like it's good for you like I said
like when I make my my curriculum for my
kids where I have the Trojan Horse for
every single problem that I think they
need it's like if you follow a religion
you know you get that be like praying
five times a day like that's staying in
touch and like keeping your brain not
fried and stuck on this nonsense which
is not like if you follow scripture and
prophecy and not religion we have to be
careful with the word religion because
it's been destroyed by Humanity by human
beings this is going in the wrong
direction and of course I wasn't that
anti-islam anymore because of what I
read what I saw and what I experienced
what I tell you now it sounds a little
like a fairy tale but it really happened
in the end there were all these books at
the table and when I had this feeling of
yeah okay this is shahada in a way I
said well I put all the books away and I
put the books on the highest shelf but
there were so many books a lot of books
fell off the shelf and one of the books
that fell off the show was the Quran and
when I picked it up my hands was on a
page with Surah 22 I had 46 and it says
it's not the eyes that are blind but but
the hearts and I thought to myself that
really is my problem because it wasn't
the eyes I really could see what I
written down myself nobody forced me to
write this book nobody said you have to
write this or that I started writing
myself and I could see it with my own
eyes but I still couldn't accept the
fact that I said he is a prophet there
is this one God I just couldn't so it
wasn't my eyes that were blind it was
really my heart I couldn't accept it I
think my nuts my nephs or whatever my
ego I couldn't accept it and I said well
God I don't care if it's the god from
the Bible or the Quran Give Me A Sign or
something so that I 100 sure know this
is the way and I went to bed but when I
woke up I felt very secure in myself I
really feel very secure I've never been
more secure about anything else the
whole anxiety or the whole doubting
issue disappeared like I love those
stories where um Mass like crazy
coincidence stories where he opened the
book is the only book that fell off the
shelf and then the page he opens to and
then the where his finger is and that's
like the whole my God but that happens
with like so much stuff like I'm not
saying that's just an Islam you start
doing what he did
and got sincerely asking God to help you
solve a problem those things happen all
the time it's not wild though like all
the time no I know you're you're not
wrong it just unfolds he wants us to ask
him for help it's actually insane it's
pretty awesome actually there's so many
stories like that like Mass coincidences
crazy right and you could just write
them off as coincidences no I know but
I'm not I'm not calling them no no I
mean somebody could very easily write
them off as coincidences but a belief
well
it I don't want to insult people who are
you know not that doesn't even mean
financially broke that means like I know
I know what you mean uh yeah I know what
you mean I I don't want to insult people
who have not come to it yet because what
I find is or I found in my own life is
that I felt like there were so many
times throughout my entire life where I
felt the presence of something bigger
and
I had a really moving moment and I and I
left it behind and I knew there was
something real there but I left it
behind and got caught back up in in my
my world and my [ __ ] and there were
people who came into my life at
different times who tried to bring me
closer to God and I just kept ignoring
them and kept ignoring them and then
there was a time when all of a sudden I
was ready for the message and I took it
and it's taking over my whole life in
the best possible way so I don't I don't
like I want to insult people who haven't
come to it yet and the idea you know
calling them I mean it's not a bad thing
though like you had the broken mentality
at one point no but it's not you know
what I'm saying like I'm not you think
you're just I don't my bad no I guess I
guess what what the thing is is that
what I'm learning is you know where if
you go to all you know all the teachings
of Jesus that he's just said pray for
people pray that they pray that their
their hearts of stones turned to a heart
of Flesh and pray that actually I don't
know if that was older New Testament to
be perfectly honest I think it was new
pray for them that that God finds them
and touches their heart pray pray for
your enemies when they're hurting you
instead of hating them pray for them and
show them love and and that's how we get
people out of that because many of us
are born with that those blinders on
really that's what happens we have
blinders on until we don't what was the
reaction of the people around you when
you became Muslim but most of them are
very negative yeah of course for a lot
of people especially some uncles and
aunts it was kind of a shock they heard
it when it was on the news I told my
mother and my mother started crying and
my wife was pretty imagine what this was
like for him to go from Christianity and
then say I'm becoming a Muslim because
as a born and raised Catholic as you
know I considered myself a cultural
Catholic I am getting pushback from
friends and family on going deeper into
religion like all of a sudden I have a
relationship with God With Jesus that I
never had before and it's not just about
phoning it in and showing up for the
sacraments and I am starting this Bible
you know the Seminary class uh in two
weeks and I'm getting weird reaction
from it so I'm getting pushback and I'm
getting the like Oh Yeah from the
religion you legit grew up yeah you
became right imagine I left it and
became Muslim which has this like
terrible reputation so even among
Christians within Christianity I'm being
kind of marginalized for becoming more
Christian it's like not it's so strange
this had to be really kind of scary
because I I was over Christmas when I
was home when we were up visiting Boston
I talked a little bit about my about
this with my pastor and I said it's
really it's really lonely it feels
really lonely to have something become
so important in my life so meaningful
and Powerful to me and not be able to
talk about it with the people that I've
been closest with for my whole life
because they don't want to talk about it
they think it's weird and that sucks
yeah so this so it feels like I have to
work really hard to not talk about it
that much and you know continue to
Foster the relationships that matter to
me in the way that I always have even
though some of the things we try talk
about Aaron is important to me or I see
them through a whole different lens so
this guy I can't even imagine what that
did to his relationships I'd like to
hear more about it he said his wife was
cool about it I mean even with you you
know like if I have a song on or
something you'll be like oh the Jesus
music and I'm like yeah you know this is
what's making me better you know it's
like making fun of somebody who's fat
and they're eating a salad like why are
you eating the salad what's that gonna
do for you you know when they're trying
to change their life like in any sort of
way making fun of somebody for trying to
do something that's going to fulfill
them and make them a happier person oh
here I remember when I was back home
hanging out with friends and there was
like a bunch of kids and like we started
talking about my YouTube and they're
like so what's up with like the Muslim
videos like what's up with that it's
like a joke and I'm like I mean bro like
a quarter of the population is Muslim
and to devote their lives to it you
don't think that's like something that
you should probably learn about like
you're on this planet for 90 years like
doesn't hurt to like look into it and
like right like what like I'm getting
like made fun of or like looking into it
because it's like such a weird
connotation it's it is really um and if
people are saying that to your face like
what are they saying behind you know our
backs like oh well oh God they're
getting all what are they getting weird
who knows and that sucks it sucks to be
marginalized but I don't give up I don't
care but when you get when I like where
I'm going and what I'm becoming a part
of is is so fantastic and the people
that I am I'm finding people now that I
can have these conversations with and
they're such beautiful conversations and
they're so fun for me
um that I'm okay with it but it's not
easy cool about it she said well if
Islam is what you really believe and
that's in your heart who am I and yeah
some people from my old work were really
aggressive I got over a 2 000 death
threats from people who used to support
me of course people who voted for me
people said the most horrible things we
will rape your wife that's always the
worst
um and it's it's crazy to see when um
you're like close with somebody and then
you you know you go and make a different
decision that's not like you know it's
not bad or it's not like malintentioned
like that's not bad intentioned at all
you're just doing your own thing and
then those people like completely switch
up on you like I remember back in like
the first like online program that I
joined the 4X one which was like
ultimately like a pyramid scheme MLM and
like you're in there and inside you feel
like everyone's like we were family you
know yada yada yada like you're my
brother now like you know like we're
doing all this and it's like you know
you you you're learning about finance
and stuff together and building
mentality and then you leave and it's
just like
did you just get like middle fingers
from all of them and it's like just
weird how it's like you were like trying
to calm your brother and like being like
all like that and then you just I don't
know it was real and then there's hating
on me and then there's haters and um and
then you never speak again it's just I'm
supposed to show how insincere that love
is yeah no it's it was crazy though I've
learned so much about people and um
everything in the last couple years I'm
so grateful for all the lessons I've
learned it's been wild I know where your
children go to school stuff like that
then most of them of course are is
nonsense because they're crazy people
writing things on their computer so it
was kind of a hectic time uh and I had
to tell my work of course and it was
this Christian organization so to say
the leader of the back he said I can't
believe it and he said well I I noticed
this change when you talked about
certain topics on radio you were kind of
a little more mild not so harsh anymore
but you becoming a Muslim and after I
said yeah I became a Muslim he said I
couldn't sleep for it for two days I
couldn't accept it it was so so strange
but the hardest part for me was telling
my grandfather because my grandfather
was dying and it was 93 94 years old and
he was on his deathbed at home I had to
tell him and my mother told me yeah you
have to tell your grandfather was his
her father so I said well then you have
to come with me you get like a shield
and I just said well grandfather I I
became a Muslim and then he closed his
eyes and I thought he stopped breathing
because yeah he was so old and he really
stopped breathing for a while and then
he started breathing again and he looked
at me and he said well at least you did
it became Catholic
so that's very funny the last thing that
my old boss from the radio he said well
how do we know that you're not becoming
Hindu one day or something else or and I
thought children well I never chose a
religion one time and it was when I
became a Muslim before that I didn't
choose my religion I was born in a
Christian family I was raised in a
Christian way and I'm very grateful for
all the good things that had brought me
but it was not my decision and the only
time I made a decision was me becoming a
Muslim and I was the most like I said I
think the most important decision I made
and it was the most rational decision I
made I never took years and years to
decide one thing only becoming a Muslim
how did you feel when you made your
first Salah it's of course a beautiful
moment but very strange as well because
as a Christian you're not used to pray
like that you pray with your hands
together and perhaps on your knees in
front of your bed or something but I
think it's very beautiful that you
really prostrate so you really bow down
in the deepest way for your lord so
that's a very humbling beautiful thing I
think and that yeah it made me feel very
happy what were the three biggest
challenges you faced when you converted
to Islam well becoming a Muslim of
course was a big challenge because I had
to tell the world a family and it was a
big challenge the part of thinking that
it would be very hard to become a Muslim
because especially as a Protestant
Christian there aren't so many things
you have to do in a religious sense as a
Muslim in terms of practice so it is
required to pray five times a day it's
required to eat in a certain way it is
required to think in a certain way you
have to be the best in a way every
moment because of relation with your
Creator and because of the fact that you
have to pray five times a day it's a
constant reminder in a way of the
Creator so that makes you much more
aware of the fact that you have a lord
than as a Christian that's how I
experience and I thought to myself whoa
five times a day praying I cannot do
this I cannot do that I have to do so
that made it hard in the head but after
I became Muslim it wasn't hard at all
because I don't want to forget I'm not
the smartest guy you know how when um
let's say you're making like a thousand
dollars a week and the brokies they'll
just go and they'll spend that whole 4
000 and I'm like you know that if you
took even like two three hundred of that
and you just put it somewhere else and
didn't touch it your lifestyle would
stay exactly the same yeah exactly the
same so that's like a really interesting
point that he made where he's like oh
well pray five times a day like I have
stuff to do it's like dude once you
start doing it it's it's not a problem
at all your your life realistically does
not not stay the same but you're not
like losing time that like everyone it's
not that big of a loss if anything
you're losing time doing dumb stuff like
you're not scrolling on Instagram as
much you're coming you're getting more
in touch with reality and then your your
time is better focused on important
things and all of us you're getting
exactly like all of us like we scroll on
social media and it's like what are we
looking at like what are we gaining it's
just nonsense it's it's complete garbage
and then we're here complaining about
how we don't have time it's like bro you
have so much time it's absurd look at
your screen time what do you mean you
don't have time yeah we we have plenty
of time we make time for what matters to
us so that that part of yes take just
the money part you know take some money
put it aside because you want more money
so then you'll have more money if you do
that but no but like your lifestyle
doesn't change it might change a little
bit there might be a few things that you
you you know you can't have a a moment
of retail therapy I'm telling you it's
actually like insane like it doesn't
change well that's funny because that's
what they say about tithing that you
know if you if you think you only have
enough money and you can't make it you
get I make a thousand dollars a week and
I need every penny of it to pay my bills
God wants you to give 10 back to him the
day you get it every every time you get
somebody gives you a hundred dollars in
a Christmas card give ten dollars to God
everything that comes to you and uh what
he does is it doesn't change your life
you [ __ ] you your ends meet your ends
manage to meet yeah but I also just
don't know how I feel about that because
it's like I've seen so much corruption
well you yeah I think you have to be you
know even like Charities like that was
so no I know I know but it's like I've
seen like when I made a big I've made
big donations to Charities and it's like
you go and then you see how like it runs
and you're like oh my God right
you have to be smart about that but you
you still should be giving it back to
God that's the law that's the biblical
law and the idea is that like you said
your life doesn't change you actually
manage to make ends meet so he was
saying about things that he you know new
rules to follow things he had to give up
things he had to do and I find that I
just don't want to do all the things
that I used to do because I have this
other sense of fulfillment I don't need
you know I don't drink nearly as much as
I was last week I went out and I drank
too much and I was dying because like I
have no my tolerance is so down because
I'm just not doing the things that I was
and I'm there's a fulfillment that comes
with this that makes it okay to make
sacrifices and I think that's where you
know he's getting he's getting at here
it's okay raising your kids as Muslims
well you try of course I don't know when
when you're really raced as a Muslim
it's I think it's a very difficult job
especially in these times of course when
I married I wasn't a Muslim you promised
in a way that you raise your children as
Christians so after I became Muslim I'm
not raising my children as Christians of
course if the kids have questions about
Christianity they ask my wife they get
Christian answers and if they come to me
they get Islamic answers but most of the
times just ask your father and my wife
cooks Halal for everybody so it's very
sweet she says well I'm not going to
cook five meals so everybody eats the
same you want Halal Everybody Eats Halal
so in a way it's it's like an organic
process what was your heaviest I mean
that's not bad at all like I mean from
what I've seen it's it's like just meat
and you know not like a whole field in a
horrible way hello all just means good
the opposite of Haram
can we get hold on me can you like I
don't know I don't know anything about
cooking in the Muslim religion I will
look yeah yes I'll make you some Muslim
food I don't know what that means
somebody sent me some recipes oh wild
steak or some something what's the
difference between a Halal steak well
from what I saw with the three Muslims
like a big thing was like how they kill
the animals okay right so that's similar
with kosher meat I guess yeah but they
said you can like taste the difference
when like an animal is raised and like a
non-terrible way not you know in a in a
box with a million other things
squishing next to it and then it's
killed with a gun to its head you can
literally I I I wouldn't I would buy
that and there are actually there's
actual scientific proof that it's
different because they look at the um
the fear adrenaline hormones that go
that go are released into the muscles
before death or are just in the muscles
from their whole life of living hell so
oh yeah that's a whole other
conversation I'd rather not even most
regretful expression that you used for
Islam I think Islam is a lie because
that's something I used to say Islam is
a Lie the Quran is poison but when I
said Islam is light that's the whole
religion and everything that comes with
it so that's like the highest level of
in a way yeah that's something I regret
because it was like an umbrella and
everything else was under this concept
of Islam is a lie because there was the
core thought and of course I do blame
myself and I know there are a lot of
people out there not practicing Muslims
that do so and in a way I understand it
because in a political sense and in a
social cultural sense everything is said
and done is still there I sometimes even
hear arguments from people in my old
party that I offended in a way yeah
that's something that bothers me and
that's one of the reasons that we found
it in organization it's called the ixc
Islam experience Center and we go to
schools primary school high school
college universities but also to
Departments of the government other
social organizations churches to take
away misconceptions about Islam and
share the message to show Islam its true
colors and we do it by virtual reality
with the glasses so it's a very fun
experience as well and we try to erase
in a way the things I said and done in
the past how should people research
about Islam do you advise just searching
at Google Now I would certainly not
advise Google it's the last thing I
would advise I said shut down the
computer no I think it's very important
that people read books real books with
pages and stuff I would recommend
Mohammed his life based on the early
sources of Martin links the book I
talked about earlier it's a green book
and I think it's very important for
people not just dive into Quran because
it's a very complex book and if you
don't have anybody who can teach issue
what you read especially most of the
people who don't know anything about
Islam are not fluent Arabic Classic
arabic speaking people so you will read
an interpretation of the Quran or a
translation and most of the time that's
not the real deal of course so I would
advise people just to study the sirat
study the character and the life of the
Prophet because that's what the
tradition teaches us as well his life
was the Quran he was the living Quran in
a way just study his Sunnah and I think
that is the best way of discovering
Islam what would you like to say is your
final comments I became much more happy
after I became Muslims I would like to
invite everybody to become a Muslim just
because it brings peace to your soul and
peace to your heart it is the truth it
resonates with heart and soul at least
look at it from an Islamic perspective
try to read and study the life of the
Prophet try to understand what the
Muslims believe not so much the behavior
of Muslims because there are a lot of
Muslims that don't live like Muslims
including myself that's a really
important question that is such an
important point because every time I
hear either atheists or non-practicing
Christians you know crap on Christianity
they're talking about people they're
talking about the church about
institutions that have done wrong and
gone you know gone astray they're never
really fully understanding the Bible and
the teachings it's it's never about that
yeah and that's and that's a really
important thing that we should all learn
about any religion you know look at the
core of the religion not not it's not
its followers it's true we all do but
you should look at the example of all
examples and it was the prophet and if
you study his life perhaps you find
guidance that leads you to uh to the
truth
I like that the guy was very nice and
chill it's a good story too I really I
really did like it because it is crazy
like coming from um a Christian family
to go to Muslim it's like a big deal
um yeah that was a solid video Yeah 3.8
it's got 3.5 million views so I guess a
lot of people agree with us that that
was a solid video I've I got a million
DMS about about this particular video
yeah yeah thank you for everyone who
said who sends it over I have a whole
bunch that I've received a bunch of
requests probably he's in there
somewhere that I haven't even had the
chance to to look through I gotta just
set aside an hour or two and just get
into it people are very generous with
the knowledge that they're trying to
share like I've seen this thumbnail like
a million times
but yeah sorry I'm sorry it took so long
for me to get to it there looks like
there are some other good ones on that
chat on that particular Channel there
yeah I've similar stories that was a
good video all right thank you everybody
for watching thank you guys so much for
watching make sure to like subscribe
follow me on Instagram at sunnyfaz you
got anything else Dad I'll give I'll
give a hundred dollars to someone who
follows my Instagram at sunnyfaz and
also make sure to follow my mom at
Sony's mother or don't doesn't
and
[Music]
[Music]